[Music]
I'll come everyone and good morning so
it's my pleasure to welcome back
Fredrick Schultz back to a masseur he's
a grad student in MIT is working with
saman amarasinghe and he's working he's
in the field of compiler and compiler
optimizations and high performance
computing and he has been working on
linear algebra for dense and sparse
inputs and he's going to talk about his
recent compiler which is a which is
about tensor tensor optimization thanks
say it so last year about a year ago I
came to talk about a programming
language we have called scimitar which
is for computing on graphs or sparse
systems using linear algebra and as part
of the future work I talked about the
need for like a strong compiler for
compiling sparse linear algebra and
tensor algebra well especially when the
matrices and vectors are blocked and I'm
back today to talk about that work so
we've done it in last year and we also
made it work for tensor algebra as a
general acid tensor algebra as well
which is really neat and it stands and
sparse tensor algebra so we implemented
this theory in a compiler so I'm going
to present a theory I'm implemented in
compiler called the tensor algebra
compiler which we abbreviate to taco and
this is joint work with Stephen Chow and
saman amarasinghe who are both at MIT
and schwag camille who is at Adobe and
then David legato is at the French
alternative energies and Atomic Energy
Commission so there's a lot of tensors
around everywhere these days
you find them in data analytics where
you have things dr. Netflix movie
ratings or the Amazon product reviews
all the social interactions of Facebook
and the attend sir is a generalization
of a matrix to any number of dimensions
so a vector would be a zero tensor a
matrix will be a to tensor and then you
can have three tensors like these or
four tensors and so on you also find
them in machine learning these days
where both images and these
these different inputs can be sort of as
a tensor or but operations can also be a
tensors a convolutional layer applying
that collusion layers that can be a
tensor operation or applying a fully
connected layer can be done stencil
operation or it can be a sparse tensor
operation if you're talking about sparse
neural networks but you also find a lot
of them in science engineering day they
made it possible answers made it
possible for Einstein to do is general
relativity and they're used all over the
place in quantum chromodynamics and
quantum mechanics in general and they're
also used in other places and here I
have the finite element method and the
key there is that a lot of that is
matrices sometimes you use tensors in
these kind of structural mechanics but
since we are talking about the
generalizations of matrices we also
include linear algebras all I've been
talking about applies to linear algebra
as well so we support up to so let's
look at this Amazon product reveiw
tensor so in the first dimension this
tensor has users so different names of
users and there's many users it's a huge
tensor then it's a three tensor so it
has a second dimension and that would be
product so here's the different products
the users bought in the third dimension
you have the words in the product abuse
and we should do so a prior work has
shown that if you do a factorization of
this tensor you can learn something
about what people are doing this tensor
is extremely sparse it contains the
whole tensor is 15.com Tilian zeros and
that's enough that you need about ten
percent of all the disk space in the
world to store this tensor but it only
has one point six gigabytes or about a
minus eight six one point seven billion
zeroes so not so many zeroes but for
each zero breach nonzero mean sir 1.7
billion non zeros and for each nonzero
you have 10 billion zeros so it's no way
you can store this unless you compress
it so so you have to take advantage of
this sparsity we have this kind of
extreme sparse it is quite common in
data analytics and science and
engineering is all over the place
we're starting to see some work on
sparse new
that works but you have some sparsity
they haven't gotten to this level of
sparsity yet but perhaps it should
because the human brain has about 100
billion neurons and each neuron is only
connected to about 7,000 other neurons
there is an extremely sparse system so
if you can borrow something like that we
would have this this kind of sparse it
in so one question is by being a tensor
algebra compiler and I'm going to argue
that we do need a tensor algebra
compiler so if you consider handwriting
these different expressions that we
would need enough if you're working with
linear algebra or tensor algebra you
have to the current approach with
traditional libraries we hand call them
so this is a very simple expression as
matrix vector multiplication it's sparse
matrix vector multiplication so this B
right there is sparse the eigen library
implemented this this operation they had
called that then the C sparse library
implemented a different kernel that in
one kernel multiplies B by C and then it
adds it accumulates into output and they
implemented this kernel because
sometimes you get better performance by
doing the whole operation that won't go
specifically the matrix is for
investigators if they'll come it will be
sparse - okay but right now is only the
matrix of the bars that's correct
there's two different kernels people
have called that then you have pet see
that figured out that you can add a
different vector to result also you
figure out that sometimes you can get
better performance if you also scale
both sides then the pet see learned that
to you you can also on the fly transpose
this matrix and then sometimes you want
to transpose the matrix I'm going to add
a vector so someone wrote all these
kernels because in different contexts
these different kernels give the best
performance but so Seban your
expressions are not enough because you
lose performance due to the temporal
locality loss but then you have
different sparse formats for the matrix
this bars format can be blocked they can
be a variable size block if you're
dealing with something about generalized
coordinates and it calls me doubly
compressed and now you have 132
different variables
this operation of someone has to go on
hand code then the vector can be denser
sparse
which adds more more variants both
output and input and this thing you plus
into it can be sparse and then you have
the rest of the test algebra expression
and there's an infinite number of them
and even if you only consider the binary
operations since the tensor can be on
the order you have an infinite number of
binary operations too but I'll show this
very clearly later that if you only
consider binary operations you're losing
a lot of performance you listen
sometimes asymptotically performance so
we have a cancer algebra compiler called
taco the alternative to such a compiler
is a traditional library where you have
called these kernels with that kind of
approach you have to choose a few
expressions judiciously so you choose
the most important ones with algebra
compiled you get any expression you
choose a few format with a traditional
library that you want to implement
typically CSR and CSE probably both with
the tensor algebra compiled you get many
formats with a traditional approach to
spend years hand optimizing these
kernels and this guy has spent many
years with the compiler relax because
the compiler will do it for you and this
cat has a compiler so we're gonna talk
in the rest of this ok I'm going to talk
about sparse code unless you get a sense
for sparsity I'm how the code looks like
when the sparse then we're going to talk
about intermediate representations and
the code generation that we do to
automate this code generating with these
codes then we're gonna evaluate the
first let's look at some sparse call
them data so this is a fairly simple
tensor algebra expression you have a
tensor be that you're multiplying by a
vector K so you're summing over this
dimension so it's like a matrix vector
multiplication with one more dimension
and result is a matrix so those
variables are called summation variables
because you sum over it that's K I and J
are called free variables because you
you don't sum over them so they are used
on the left-hand side of this expression
so if all of these three cancers are
dance you have a dense matrix a dance
treat answer and a dance back
then the code is quite straightforward
we can write this called easily you are
three nested loops and you do the
accumulation and multiplication in the
center of these three loops but if you
want to start making this operand sparse
so in our system you can choose whether
attempts response per dimension so for
each dimension you say this dimension
sparse or this dimension stance that
gives you many combinations of formats
like there's some thing 16 combinations
for this and 8 combinations for that so
if I make that dimension a dimension of
this the three tensors bars as I make it
sparse then the cold changes a little
bit there so instead of iterating of the
whole domain it iterates only over the
data structure the sparse data structure
in that dimension of B for make the next
dimension sparse it changed it's the
same way to make the third dimension
spot it changes the same way but if I
want to make this vector sparse then I
have to insert quite a bit of cold to
merge together this vector this sparse
vector with that sparse tensor in the K
dimension so that looks very similar to
like not join in databases if you're
doing like the inner join and if you
have a summation it looked a lot like a
three-way merge that don't work not will
described in his book on the art of
computer programming that's used in
North Shore time is used in north
showing so that the basis we generate
this kind of code then we can generate
much more general code and let's now
show that but suppose what you wanted to
do you have two sparse tensors you want
to add them you want to multiply it by
vector in the same kernel then the cold
starts to blow up and you can't write
this code anymore because there's all
these cases you have to consider and I'm
sure quite quite a straightforward
theory for how to generate these cases I
have a question about when you say it
dimension is sparse yeah does the older
matter like the order of dimensions that
you're talking about yeah left that off
you have to specify both but each team
actually stands for sparse and which
order to store data for exam for your
cancer the first dimension is as far as
it means that the entire let's let's
matrix's is gone if you say like
something is missing from the second
dimension means like the road is gone no
and then you feel okay yeah it's well if
I yeah exactly exactly what you said if
this first imagine stands like this
whole slides just disappears and then
that goes down in our system you won't
not only specify this you also specify
the order you store it mentions them so
there's a matrix you can store it in
column order which is CSC compressed
sparse column or row mail-order which is
compressed borrow Lucas basketball
specify both things I just left that out
for some place okay okay so let's look
at it so bad that's how spot sir
curious so obviously this you know as a
problem is existent for many years right
and your people have work done so what
is it that's different now that you know
white people in the 90s we're done
Fortran and you know I'm trying to do I
don't know the same kind of I'm just
curious about it but it has a problem
changed you know over the course of the
last decade I don't think the problem I
think just to be found like a new attack
ago I met a lot of people worked on the
dance problems like the Pulido a lot of
things like that and they'd made a lot
of progress there some people like the
bernoulli work from a church up in
Galilee and some work from people in in
Amsterdam try to tackle this sparse
problem but they got stuck I don't know
exactly why they didn't solve the
problem I think they got stuck in a
complexity of off they only did Fellini
algebras I think maybe that was a
problem because if you only do silly
logic but you don't see the generality
you have to go to higher dimensions to
see the generality just like a human
thing and I think they got stuck in a
complexity of the whole problem what we
figured out how to do this how to
generate this kind of code level by
level so we do it from one dimension at
a time and then you can solve the
problem locally in that dimension and
then it's a manageable problem you still
have to deal with the merchants that
we've sold that to I think they try to
solve it for generally called for a
whole thing in at once
yeah yes I think maybe what changed
about the problem is that we thought
about it as tensors and then you because
it's more generalize you see the
generality I start with more general we
actually started first just between
algebra and the theory got simpler when
we generalize the tensors which is kind
of cool yeah they're the most related
prior work is capture pink always been
all the work from the night this it was
at Cornell at the time so so that was
the their sparse and that's cold
and now I'm gonna look at this part in
dense data so this is the same three
tensor but I've unrolled it so the three
matrix slices are shown here so if this
is a dance format I lay it out in memory
linearly and notice that these
coordinates form a complete tree and I
it's important because since they form a
complete three I can locate an element i
have random access i can look at the
element but just computing this formula
which is just so strided formula then I
get straight down to the element side
random access is an important property
but I waste a lot of data because all
these are empty and almost store them so
I want a compassed storage format what I
do I remove all the zeros I shove all
these non zeros next to each other and
now I don't have a complete three
anymore so these can't be kept in place
that you have to store these illnesses
so I start by storing the first
illnesses in the I dimension then I
store in the Cecilia J dimension then I
store for each I which J is correspond
to a tie then I store the case then for
each j IJ cognition which case
correspond to that and that gives me
quite a general format so the compressed
Marsh row format for matrices has one of
these sets of indices
if it was a doubly compressed bash row
you will have two sets in tensors you
just keep going and you add one on one
on one on top of it this is sometimes
called a compressed sparse fiber format
we can generate code for this and we can
generate code with some of them advanced
as well as I made combination and then
you have for each of these just which
values corresponds
that's just by possession you don't have
random access so you lost that but
typically when you compute you can if
you merge things together you don't need
random access you just scan over the
whole format I'll show that so if you
want to locate a value with like the
same value has to be located earlier
then you have to scan across that row
you have to consider all the values on
that row you scanned across the J's
until we find J zero you consider all
the case for left J zero and then you
scan the case until you find it you
don't so you lose sort of you lose
random access you can do this but it's
expensive and what is format us is that
decreases dependency chain through your
index variables and those index
variables are going to correspond to
your loops so now you have dependency in
your loops and they say this is a key
observation and we call this an
iteration graph and I will show how it
works in general so now I'm going to go
into intermediate representation and
code generation which is our compiler
it's our compiler so we call it top comb
that's an acronym for tensor algebra
compiler the way it works is that it
takes in a tensor expression and the
tensor expression it can be any number
of operands and for each operand you
have to say the format of that opera
that's all you say then it produces C
code it produces a kernel that computes
that expression on those formats we also
have a library so you can load data and
all those things as well
internally it turns your expression into
an iteration graph then from the
iteration graph it produces code and
when it produces code it uses this
concept we call the merge lattice that's
a new concept we've developed to deal
with this arbitrary emerges because you
don't want only want to be able to
binary merges you want to deal with like
merging three operands for app runs on
any number of operands so
see so I'm we're going to look at how
the iteration space looked and we're
going to build up to this iteration
graph and see what iteration graph comes
from so it comes from these formats but
it also comes from your expression so if
you want to compute this expression you
have to iterate or all the combinations
of I J and K so it's gonna be three
loops and the iterator all that's whole
expression so you can think of that as
three dimensions in a polyhedron so now
we're moving towards the polyhedral
model at each location in this
polyhedron you're going to access B so
you're accessing B through this
polyhedron so it's a it's a three
dimensional raccattack racc tangle here
but then you have to access k as well
and this case only one dimensional it's
only one of this but you're going to
access this for each IJ so you can think
of it as replicating this let us see or
cross the whole iteration space then
when you do the computation you have to
merge these together and compute the
multiplication so this is the polyhedron
model at the heart of it you have these
affine whole hedron's like this but they
have no holes like they're the danced
polyhedrons and kampala community has
spent many years like figuring out how
to compile stuff like this and we made a
lot had a lot of success with that in
the 80s and 90s and 2000's but
applications have been moving towards
sparse representations and a compiler
community has to catch up to that we
have to give them some support and we
can think of this in a sparse way as
polyhedrons with hole so now we have a
sparse polyhedron and this creates some
opportunities and some problems that we
have to solve we don't know where these
holes are at compile time and but and it
cannot touch these holes because I
mentioned it Amazon tensor if you touch
these holes you you will never finish so
you have to generate code that avoids
touching the holes but I can compute the
values where you have non zeros so I put
back this this dependency chain through
the iteration variables that corresponds
to this tensor I'm going to have a
similar dependency change for the tape
before this for a C vector so this
turn here and dependency chain on the
bee doctor when I merged them together
and merge these possible hedron's I
wasn't merged together these two
iteration growths so now you have this
dependency chain on you have a merge
here this collision there so if I want
to do that multiplication I have to
intersect the two sparse polyhedrons and
then compute the intersection and that
that's this multiplication then finally
I'm going to add in a which is resolved
there's a dependency on result two so
what this iteration graph shows is the
dependence is imposed by the sparse data
structure and we're going to use this
one for cogeneration here so much we can
generate the situation grows for any
expression there's a general
representation and here's some examples
from linear algebra and tensor algebra
so this goes from the matrix vector
multiplication all the way down to this
is the entity car key that you use for
factorizing tensors this is a block
matrix vector multiplication which turns
into a for cancer operation in our
representation we just blocked matrix is
at for cancer it's more blocked is 6:06
tensor so forth so let's look at this
expression again I'm now going to look
at code generation so we have the
iteration graph we generated that from
from the formats and and the expression
I'm gonna generate cold so if the first
dimension of B was dance then it's very
simple we can generate the banns loop so
this gets back to what I was talking to
talking about a little earlier which is
we can generate code for each level
separately so this level I can ignore
everything down here we have a recursive
code generator our goodness just going
to recurse on this and generate about a
generate code for each level the first
the first level this is dense you can
just make this loop second level if B
was sparse you can emit a sparse loop
the complexity comes comes in when you
have a much emerging a sparse beam with
a sparse e so now you have to make this
merge code and I'll talk about how to do
that next and then at the center you
have to make a compute statement
so this March is what we call a
conjunctive March it's an intersection
you want to produce the values in up it
wherever both be in the third dimension
and see has a value because a
multiplication by by zero disappears
course bigger they say anything any
dimension do you store them in order
like this is so because that is
necessary for all of this computation
right good question
yes we do in this work we have future
work where BM to be in this work we have
the dance format for the mansion and the
sparse format and the sparse yes
Ashley CSR it's ordered because you
cannot do this kind of mush with a
border that we're working on for a new
birth that instead of two formats per
dimension will give you hundreds of
formats per dimension and there you can
select the properties you want if you
have ordering you can do this if you
don't have ordering you might be you
have to resort to sorting it on the fly
or do something more similar to hash
join or or something like that but that
is that's future work we're working on
right now we mostly mostly sorted that
out here it's ordered but if the vector
was dense if this vector was dance we
take advantage of that
I mean iterate over this sparse format
and then just random access this which
looks a lot like a hash join from
databases so there would be don't merge
there yeah so that's the conjunctive
merge so I'm going to look at the
conjunctiva in more detail I show how
you can generate code for it then I'm
going to show how to generate code for
disjunctive merge which comes from an
addition and then I'm going to show some
examples of how we can do that for any
expression and the combination of
additions and multiplications so this is
just an element-wise multiplication of
two vectors because since we do this per
dimension we can consider the vectors
and by solving the marsh problem for
vectors we have solved therefore whole
thing because we just do that
recursively so here's two vectors your
element was multiplied them you produce
results
wherever both have a nonzero care only
one have nonzero so you have no result
since they're sparse we enumerate in the
let me remove the non-zeros and since
this is not the full range we have to
store them so we store them then we want
to take an intersection of these and
these and the way we think about that is
using this thing so this is our motion
this is one point in our morality so
much that is an ordered lattice this is
saying that wherever so it's saying two
things it's saying it weight or both B
and C until one of them runs out of alia
that's one of the pieces of the ant this
is also saying at each point produce a
value if both B and C has a value at
that point when one of them run out the
value you drop down to the bottom
lattice point and you're done so if you
want a set value you done zero inside
value you also done because it's a
conjunct emerge so we can generate code
for this lattice point by lattice points
only one lattice point in this case so
we can generate a loop that runs while
both are values then in addition there's
a case saying if bottom value at that
point you omit the value so let's look
at how that works for this example we
start by finding the position so B and
finding the position of C so now we
initialize them here then we consider
whether either of them are Auto values C
is our values here so they still have
values then you take the minimum of B
and C at that location if both of have a
value at that location you produce an
output value then you increment both of
them that work that you had that you
that you consumed and then you keep
going until one of them runs at the
value at this point then this test will
fail are you done and that's it now for
the disjunctive much that's an addition
addition here so we have a disjunctive
merge so instead of taking the
intersection we have to take a Union
then it gets a little bit more involved
so let's look at the lattice we can't
create a lattice point that has some or
you iterate while one of them still have
values left and then if one of them have
a value you have to add value to output
because a plus zero is
eh but this is too expensive to metal
loop like that so we rewrite that
expression to this form which is a
disjunctive sequence of conjunctions so
this is the two way merge algorithm
describes in Donald it described it
dominates Berk
let me put these two points these two
terms down in this lattice structure so
what this is saying
run while both of them have Alice's left
if one of them run and value run off the
rest of the other one and added them so
to produce code for this we produce one
core one piece of one loop per lattice
point
so first loop runs about both our values
so it runs down here same as in the
previous example then then we are out of
values in C so we dropped down the C
edge here and then we have to run out
the rest of us of BS a bi-metal loop for
that yes like here disrespecting the
order of the indices not right because
if if you do the intersection first then
did the ones that intersect first come
first in girth storage right oh no this
is running this is running down here but
we don't omit cases so that we can do
all of the case in the middle here so
you run down like this until here but
you're going to omit values both where
both of us say you're gonna patch up
this way you got the blank space you're
gonna patch it up with the ones really
only as one right it's gonna be three
cases here one case they're both the
value you add up and those cases are
also going to be generated from this
lattice because though this one case per
lattice part that's dominated by the
lattice point you're currently I met in
called for and since these are dominated
only themselves there's no cases because
it's trivially just one case so the
lattice point B and C is different
whereas this challenge in large are a
conjunctive for for this one program yes
yes exactly because that's all we're
saying is before on previous slide it
looked if you door what's underneath it
look the same but now it's
different your the difference comes from
making a mess the difference here is
that you have only one case because you
don't dominate all the things it is
absolutely okay I am making a mess since
I said myself okay so you have to be
alert and then you have to be alert will
iterate until this one is out the values
and then you could have had a case where
this one had more value so you have to
make a loop for the scene at this point
- I'm now getting to these cases so it's
going to be one case in this loop for
every lattice point dominated by this so
since it dominates everything there's
going to be a case for everything the
first case is if whatever value you add
them second cases if only yes a value
you store it third case if only see you
store that did that answer the question
okay so that's also disjunctive and a
conjunctive March so but but as I said
we can do this for any expression and
I'm going to show you some examples I'm
not going to go in details on though
you're gonna see some examples so here I
have an addition that's multiplied by a
vector so the lattice looks like this
and we have in the in our paper in our
upcoming oops lab paper this year we
have the algorithm for producing
lattices from an expression so as before
you just generate a loop for each
lattice point and in inside each loop
you generate cases for each lattice
point dominated here you're adding three
vectors together so you're getting this
rather large lattice structure but
that's before you just generate code for
each lattice point
this by the way applies to databases too
because we can use this to generate code
for for arbitrary joints well what if I
make that D dance now you're going to
get a mix of this merge code and this
random access thing that turns out it's
an optimization of this mouse lattice
will you knock out some
the points because the second you're
done with D you're done because it
stunts so it covers the whole space so
that just knocks out some of these loops
it simplifies to other loops a little
bit okay so maybe support any such thing
where these can be dense or sparse okay
so that was tough this is maybe good
irrigation where 0 becomes 1 and 1
becomes 0 so accommodation that we just
kept in VR you mean very but but you
have to generational review very good
others listen - oh yeah we haven't done
that for for most sparse operations that
would be a problem you kill you pretty
quickly you have answers yeah yeah we
haven't considered that case actually
yeah we haven't written the paper about
putting this into databases yeah so yeah
so boolean negation is interesting
because that's moving this to different
semi-ring I'm a normal semi ring I mean
it started thinking about a little bit
but apparently we haven't thought about
it a lot
that'd be very cool I think then attempt
I have to think about the tough line how
does it be done I'm sure we could figure
out a way to generate that kind of cold
you just have to run over maybe maybe
it's a what you do is that you generate
all the values and then you run all the
Nancy Rossum and knock them out
and the other question for the compiler
part okay then we're going to look at
our revelation and the result is going
to be enough to be pretty fast
but before I want to have you ever seen
a revelation that doesn't say that but
first I'm going to show you guys a demo
of tacos you can so tiling it's like a -
there's two types of time you can tell
tile the data space and you can tile the
iteration space and you can use our
formats to tile the data space you can
do that like I can turn a sparse sparse
matrix into a spar spar spar spars for
cancer and a tile it that way tiny
iteration space with sparse loops that
doesn't buy you much because you have
our conditionals to figure out whether
you hit the middle point of a row for
tiny dumb spaces that makes a lot of
sense because you have random access so
you can just run up to the middle and
and jump down but we haven't done that
work yet
so but nice a result so we're very fast
I mean for spar stuff for them stuff we
don't tile so be not going to be as fast
as something like the tensor contraction
action from Ohio State that's future
work we're going to look at it next
semester
this kind of tiling iteration spaces so
that we can be fast for dance operations
as well it seems I don't have access to
the Internet it's okay I can just do it
better we have a bad page where you can
generate called in the web page but I
can do it with a command line tool too
so I can do the princess
I can type an ex-russian actually I
think I'm gonna skip this but you can
type an expression you can decide the
format's and then it will generate the
code for you in like milliseconds an
hour that page you can you can do it in
a job I'll give you interface where you
choose the dimensions with drop boxes
now that's it's kind of cute but I think
you'll take too long to set up you can
have connections it's for Thomas but it
will generate a sea library with that
Colonel for you so you can use it for
generating Cole but I'm copying advance
your application it generates a header
file with the comma yeah but we also
have a seacoast bus library that you can
hold on I just used like a linear
algebra library it's a tensor algebra
library but it you just use it by you
overloaded the C++ ik like practices
operator so that you can just define
your expression on compute so what we do
right now is that we affect expression
we run it through this thing generate C
code store the C code call the system
compile to compile the C code so dynamic
library diello and that library but we
want to we want to write the LLVM
back-end so you do that in memory but it
can pass it on the fly yes so it
requires some compiler infrastructure at
runtime if you don't have a compiled
infrastructure if your local
supercomputing node then you can use the
offline library to generate the current
as you need
I'll go on to Revelation so there's
there's two main stories in yourself the
first is that there's an infinite space
of tensor algebra kernels this is
there's a lot of them and some of them
some points in this space have been hand
optimized by someone summer others have
not but I'm gonna show this for for the
ones that have some sparse abroad where
as fast as the one that has been hand
optimized for someone but we have the
same performance for everything else so
wherever people haven't hand optimized
that you have two alternatives you can
use this or you can use an alternative
system that's much lower than us
there's a few general systems like the
MATLAB tensor toolbox or you can hand
optimize it yourself and get the same
performance as you would get from our
system the second thing is that the
second story is that there's no
one-size-fits-all
format some formats are good for some
matrices and tensors and some form is a
good for others you have to have a
system that can give you in many formats
so that you can shape your format to
your data so let's look at the very
simplest one of the very simple
expressions so the reason why I don't
show results for a sparse matrix vector
multiplication that this is the kernel
that people has been most effort and
optimizing so the implementations in in
library start MPL is very fast so in
matrix vector multiplication of a sparse
matrix you multiply it by a dense vector
to produce a value in output you do a
dot product of this sparsh row with this
dance factor the results are here this
is taco I'm del bosque which is written
for auto tuning at Berkley eigen you bus
and this thing which is part of I
believe boost so this results show that
we are comparable performance sometimes
we're a bit slower so this is normalized
time it's the lower is better sometimes
we bit slower than I'm Carol which is
really a really good library sometimes
we're a bit faster so it's it's about
the same the y axis the different inputs
the matrices from laura larae sparse
matrix collection
national setup first there's normal
election the fact that there just isn't
really that's right I mean there is no a
lot to do here in the sense of
performance so it's not gonna be fast
it's not random access so really what
you're gaining is the fact that you can
just handle anything and you're nice you
know regular format yeah for this
operation that's exactly you right about
10 lines of code and that's the best you
can do pretty much the software
prefetching it's not buying you a lot
and if it was buying you a lot and we
can generate software prefetching to you
but it's not buy me a lot because you
bound I think on the length of the store
buffer you do have random access into
the vector which means you don't have to
admit you are cold so it's really not
that bad posture ah so in case where Cal
does do better yeah you look good to see
what to see why I mean it should be
pretty easy to yeah well we don't have
the call from Cal me think it's because
these are small matrices so they fit in
cash I'm done they do a better job
apparently and we do a better job when
it doesn't fit in cash but that is a
hypothesis I haven't gone and verified
that you know clearly examine setup
possible implementation choose the most
optimal idea so there it is but it's not
search through there's no special
abilities given given like one
expression like this expression and one
format for matrix you have no choice you
have to follow the format in the
direction format goals some of them are
dense then you have more then you can
tile the iteration space we don't do
that we don't support that moment so
yeah we can't generate coma that's if
it's all dance operations we are not the
fastest one out there you can tell the
data space though so if you do that then
you can get good performance with us why
are these batteries if there's many 1
min here
please so what is this there's a
difference coming they're not that
different though this is almost within
the noise I think I again is a little
slower because they use some
abstractions like iterators and template
metaprogramming that might not produce
the best code so this is normal as time
so this is one so maybe this is five
time to sound
yeah it could I don't know the answer to
that but it could be so this is a
particular sparse representation yeah
this is sex or yeah okay so depending on
the birth of man he could actually have
great results - right right right
I will troll it later if out happens if
you have different matrices do you have
to choose different representations of
the metrics like you can't use CSR for
every matrix some matrices you have to
use a different format and then you have
to choose the right format - and that
the choice of the format will guide how
the code looks so then you will actually
search different codes and you will find
the best code okay but you have a VM is
parallel code - and when we emit
parallel code we're much faster than non
parallel ones of course in tell em tell
us as parallel code so we are done we're
comparable now we're actually maybe a
little faster shared memory parallel 1
single socket yeah because the way be
initialized memory right now we can't on
multiple sockets because the first touch
policy
- policies and memory placement policy
will kill us but we ability we can solve
that easily we just haven't done that so
it's shared memory yeah this is you can
just look up that inspector yeah so the
way they paralyze it we paralyzed our
absolute this is CSR
so erm
this goes a mantra that goes on the road
threat they gather from this vector in
parallel each of these produced bomb
outputs of the snow interference output
this was a CSV format you would have to
synchronize them out because you're
scattering into output but if there is
loading now like I have a lot more non
series it appears that then it's taking
that yeah stuff like that become so
there is no dynamic works because
younger I've called diffuse itself and
then you solve that problem with the
runtime but we don't do anything for
that like most of the optimizations for
SPMD has been focusing on how do you
change the data so that the data access
pattern is better and you can do that
with with this approach to you just do
that was outside when we get the data we
access it in that order that's sort of
orthogonal to call generation right so
these are very sparse I don't I can say
all of them I think most of them are our
constant number of non-zeros on each row
so the more Dmitri Scrolls the the lower
this part the Lord is partially cuts
so this partially grows om the size of
matrix groans one square that's very
common because of locality in the world
experience say that if you have 90% of
those fast array
that's how do you come here is dance
performance right I have to bring a
floor so I did not put that in our talk
I should have had a backup slide on it
forgive me that I'm bringing up a paper
here but we have that graph
that's the couple of point so
okay so what this is saying is that for
spme sparse matrix vector multiplication
if 66% of your values are dance you're
the same if so if you have more than 35%
thirty four percent zero stand you
you're better off with the sparse sparse
format this is a surprising result this
does not match your result from the
Oscar PhD thesis but this is what we
have found them we're pretty confident
in that result we see about like 80 90
percent of the sparsity it's not super
fast but we hope to take evaluations we
think your time policy yeah that
probably that comes from the
vectorization better that why that 35
percent make sense it could be the
factorization matters less because the
memory bandwidth is about mcnally that
could be okay
so let's look at I'm gonna look at two
more operations this is a motor matrix
operation if you forgive me I'll do
another linear algebra long because this
shows us something very interesting the
next one will be a tensor 1 this is
sampled M stands matrix multiplication
comes from data analytics it's taken
from a PhD thesis at Berkeley you
element-wise multiply this is you
multiply two matrices and a new element
was multiplied that with a sparse matrix
so you have a dense matrix you multiply
it by a dense matrix that gives you 64
in the products but your element was
multiplied by a sparse matrix which
means that you only have to produce you
have to do this dot product wherever you
have a nonzero here so if I have a non
zero there I have to do this dot product
but there's only ten of these guys I
don't have to produce this dot product
so that brings me now to ten in the
product so here you have to implement
this whole thing in one kernel if you
implement this to binary kernels and
compose them you lose a lot of
performance so this shows that this is
like a general thing that happens
outside of linear algebra to where when
you compose these high-performance
libraries the first library might do
that the next library chose away that's
one problem the next issue if you
compose libraries without sort of doing
this kind of approach you use temporal
locality and the third problem is that
you might end up omitting data from one
library then you have to reorganize that
data you go into the next library
because it expects a different layout so
they don't really compose the problem
here I was talking to Madonna and told
them so it about it earlier is that term
we are handwriting we sort of
handwriting these specific routines that
work on one layout and then we composing
them with the by changing the data but
we think we believe that you need to
shape the call to adapt to the data you
don't adapt the data to the cold you
generate the code for the data you have
and then when you compose two libraries
you generate call to use that format
next library generates call to produce
you to use the same formats you get
friction-free
and this is another example where you
need that so the performance here shows
eigen does this operation they can be in
one go so we have similar performance
again little noise back and forth you
Blas does do does this as two binary
operations and then you just performance
stars and which is expected on this
performance this this number of axis is
going to go up the more the sparsity of
B increases so there's an asymptotic
sort of difference depending um but this
is om 1 0 or om square non-zeros then
you have MTD Kalki which comes from
tensor factorization in this operation
you have three index variables the index
in two or three tensor use some one of
them with one matrix and the other one
with another matrix this is the main
kernel in the canonical poly object
factorization for boat answers this is a
sparse operation you have to do it in
one kernel
otherwise the temporaries will kill you
to do this in one column we generate
code to do that and MATLAB status a
toolbox has a sort of an interpreter
approach where they take the tensor they
transpose it so that it looks like an
flattened matrix then they call matrix
libraries and then they transpose it
back the sort of shape it if hit
routines that are available
but the performance is quite quite
lacking in this approach for this
operation dude if you generate exactly
right cold you get good performance and
splat is recent birth by Shaitan Smith
at the University of Minnesota he ran a
hand optimize this this colonel and he
gets excellent performance better
performance are offs we generate code
that gets comparable performance to him
a little worse in most cases a little
better there we know about this
differences and I mention it on my last
slide how we gonna fix this so what this
shows is that you have to you have to
generate conferees for Colonel Moore go
find the final aberration will show that
different matrices matter for different
different format matters for different
matrices so here you have dense matrix
and here's the SPM the performance
that's all the form is a row major and
this is the matrix vector multiplication
the dance format is the best format
course pradhans matrix but if a change
is the thermal matrix looks at that you
want the Dunsparce format as CSR because
you have something on each row but most
rolls don't have much values so you want
to compress the second dimension but not
both dimensions than your little worse
if that's like a row / methods you slice
dense matrix you want the sparse dance
format and if it's a hyper sparse matrix
which is starting to see in that
analytics you want the sparse parse
format so there's no one-size-fits-all
different format matters for different
matrices you have to conform them to
each other and when you conform them to
each other you have to generate correct
code finally this is a blocked at the
end matrix so here you have three by
three blocks because you're simulating
in three dimensions with these kind of
met resource for us this is a for cancer
so you can generate code for block
linear algebra this becomes a for tensor
operation this is spme bestest
blocked operation and here so here you
storing after atom sparse constants that
is the block compressed partial format
and that will be the best format if you
don't take advantage of the block and
you lose a lot of performance because
you don't get a vectorized Oz
dance loops so um that is what I was
going to talk about here so let's say we
have a very complicated expression do
you have to introduce it fast for summer
let's see one expression results in ijk
two rather expression is listening ikj
yeah transpose will show up as a cycle
in the duration graph which we don't
support so you have to transpose it
there baby
so an expression with the transpose you
have to transpose before and then feed
it into expression because the transpose
you you are trying to access so you're
running or the format of the input but
you have to access the other one in
reverse order so you have to do random
access but these stats so you see
there's like a partial order all images
in your expression what do these kind of
expression show up in practice transpose
expressions absolutely okay
I showed some in the beginning with
Patsy which did a transpose D that
expression we can do it because you're
multiplying it by a vector so it's okay
you're not producing a sparse matrix but
if you're doing a single transpose to a
sparse matrix maybe a hand called the
death but our theory cannot generate
code for that
that's future work too so that's I
didn't put it on here but it's one of
the future works we want to have
portability so you want to do GPUs we
looked at super taco which is super
computing person many more formats this
gives us the optimization that Sheldon
did with amphitheater P this will also
give us this stuff since matrix matrix
multiplication algorithm for sparse
matrices that are working on that now
and it's almost done we want our
scheduling language for the tiling we
want different some earrings and you can
do a lot of work on policy because we
give you our code generation mechanism
next question is what called you want to
generate so I think we're um so how I'm
time we're at a time right okay then I
will skip
I will skip I was going to talk about
the workplaces I will skip it but
acceleration so there's these TPS and I
know invidious also working on that
maybe they already a hardware sports
tensor operators at the hardware level
um how did those affect this I mean do
you just sort of them there's another
layer that compiles your outfit to that
is that basically the way to think about
it yeah that's a really good question so
for the tip use that would be a
different back-end for us so we can
compile to tip you the the Google TPU
looks like it's some fast matrix matrix
multiplication engine so we would have
to generate little matrix matrix
multiplications that that could use for
Nvidia stuff my my group at MIT is
writing a grant with the media now to
use this as a compiler for their custom
GPUs GPU nuts but what we are trying to
purchase the TP use shouldn't be as hard
called as Google's TPU because when you
have something like this you can
generate a TPU de the certain operations
like this mergers really fast but that
we can shape general code we don't have
to sort of fit exact hard code the thing
they have you want more program bolt
abuse because then we can use this
better hardware and support at some
level then you haven't explored that
directly that's right but they have to
match as well otherwise you get friction
yeah you have to shape everything to fit
just like I have in the clock yeah like
a natural direction to investigate so
it's certainly because at some point
these things are rolling out you know
hardware and hardware is hard to change
at some point you know it seemed body
couldn't read the first I think that
makes like the case even more for a
compiler because you don't want to hand
write the code for all these kernels and
then like I show you the exponential
explosion like different platforms is
another axis of that explosion so then a
compiler would be more useful but it's
future work to actually do it so special
education sorry sorry I mean do these
devices are even GPUs through the help
and as
that's past GPS oh yeah there's much
work from Myrtle garland school but the
video showing that the GPU is are quite
quite a good sparse matrix vector
multiplication action and even as part
metric metrics is because I'll give you
a smaller floating-point operations but
it also has like ten times the bandwidth
so you can load values from memory
really question you can hide like
latency if they're barreling and that's
in there a lot of them are expressed as
dance operations but there's in Berk
especially for build dollies at Stanford
looking at sparse neural networks and
tell you so you have they're typically
in a fully connected layer you have a
weight matrix you want to multiply by
like a input domain and that bit may
both matter it's doing learning you
cannot go out non-zeros and it doesn't
affect accuracy that much and then you
create as part of this so I the way I
think I like to think about it is that
if the neural network is a brain it's a
sparse system you just don't know what
this and you're trying to find that
sparse system by sort of capping some
non zeros to zero but you have to
artificially create that during learning
in some sense none of the sparsity is
actually dynamic but if you do have god
answer answer but in practice
make around 50 50 to 60 percent of them
are likely to be 0 but you don't know if
it's 60 percent of them on its purchase
yes it changes and so would you be able
to make use of that because you have to
convert that into a sparse
representation yeah that's a that's a
really really good question so what
we're finding in our new Birkin format
this work which we are doing now with
peas in my group is that for a situation
like that packing it into something like
CSR is too expensive but coordinates is
sort of the national format you list up
all the non zeros you don't have to pack
with coordinates it's friction-free
so coordinates might make the
computation a little slower but since
you don't have any import cost the you
would be able to take advantage of
that depending on how Spartacus but with
this since you have no like friction in
sort of packing yet yeah it doesn't
really matter that they change is that
for training definitely is dynamic that
touches them ways to get some acid
environment powerful inference harder
static posturing
so maybe for inference if it's nothing
you can use something our CSR that's
more compressed and then for other you
can use coordinates which is little less
compressed because you don't compress
the coordinates nickel Marcus the matrix
you compress but the coordinate three is
not compressed so you take a little bit
of a hit but you don't get the packing
coaster yeah
yes the last thing I will say is that
all of this is available on github
you know MIT license you can use those
library or you can use this web
interface that just lets you generate
expressions you have to give an it is a
standard that's just like the VPD
this just says you have to acknowledge
us okay that's that's right yeah it's
not a custom I'm like yeah yeah so the
web page you can generate kernels and
play with formats and all that are you
aware companies they're using this thing
yes I've been talking to tile DB which
is a startup that does databases around
spar scientific data like bio genetic
data and they're very interested to
building the compute engine about this
and I'm talking to some people from the
government you also want to use it for
for star for everything except this
JavaScript yeah but if you wanted this
job
this just calls a server that compiles
her shut everything is there yeah baby
don't keep anything back your kernel can
be a school Alex right sorry which is
the basic operators to too few things
into okay yeah that's that's like the
answers can be a little too park bus you
can have any size of the kernel like any
size but if you have a lot of additions
the mercial ethicists will grow
exponentially doubly exponentially I
believe which will if you're adding say
five sparse matrices you'll have 100
megabytes of cold so we give you that
you could be generated happily for you
but you should not ask for it if we give
you a lot of power but power comes
responsibility
so very complicated marches of additions
there wants to grow it up you want to
cut up the expression into multiple
expressions and want to think about like
a system written on top of that audacity
is policy decisions for you I would be
very interesting research for
multiplications verges on multiplication
you don't get a problem so if you have
mixes of addition some of the occasional
multiplication will cut down the space
of the bursh lattices with the
compilation time millisecond but you can
see it right here right
is that real time yeah just goes like
that's going like to a server to call
command-line tool to that's that's yeah
well of course if you have black eyes
really
companyís addition I may produce 100
watt or call will take a while to right
now confuse confuse I don't think I'm an
exploit but thrill
it's linear in the size photograph but
not like this like complicating our
analysis will cause it to I think grow
out it's a really complicated motion
atlases will produce all of the cold and
it's linear in the number of nuttiest
points but it is a recursive algorithm
so if you have like a merge that is at
one point it'll have to be cursed and
for each lattice part because it's
marching in this dimension but then it
was lots of sub cases but it's linear in
that size so the completion time is not
a problem
[Applause]